breaking news this Thursday night the
coronavirus now declared a global health
emergency we're all in this together and
we can only stop it together the World
Health Organization praises China's
response as some Canadians criticize
Ottawa it's been rudderless a global
news exclusive new revelations about
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's
disastrous trip to India
good news for smokers why it's never too
late to bat out and the footwear dubbed
a runner's soulmate believe you can
track the shoes taking off controversy
in competitions
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about the new corona
virus outbreak the World Health
Organization has now declared it an
international public health emergency
it's concerned countries with weak
health care systems may not be able to
cope the w-h-o stressed 99% of cases are
in China and it praised that country's
response the numbers though keep rising
Chinese authorities are reporting more
than ninety four hundred confirmed cases
worldwide now the vast majority are in
China and there are thousands more
suspected cases there every province in
mainland China now has confirmed cases
on this map the darker the red the
higher the number Wuhan the capital of
Huub a province where this outbreak
began has the most over 1,000 cases 213
people have now died from this new
strain of coronavirus all of them in
China and the w-h-o says China which has
put millions of people under quarantine
is rapidly building new hospitals to
handle all the sick people - it says it
set a new standard for outbreak response
I have never seen in my life this kind
of mobilization the measures they are
taking which I believe will reverse the
tide but not only what they're doing is
protecting their people but I know from
the figures also you know that it's
protecting the rest of the world there
are no more than 100 confirmed cases
outside mainland China they're scattered
across to at least 19 countries and
territories India has now confirmed its
first case and so has the Philippines
Canada's health minister says the risk
here remains low and declaring a global
health emergency does not change that
the government is still working on a
plan to airlift Canadians trapped in
Wuhan the center of the outbreak we'll
get to that in just a moment but we
begin with Redman Shannon on the w-h-o
declaration and what it means this was
the World Health Organization's third
emergency meeting on the corona virus
outbreak
and on this occasion after hours of
debates the panel voted to declare a
global health emergency the main reason
for this declaration is not because of
what is happening in China but because
of what is happening in other countries
the head of the w-h-o repeatedly praised
China's response to the outbreak saying
it can turn the tide it's actually doing
more than China is required to do this
is to protect especially countries with
weaker health system labeling this a
global health emergency means more
international resources for prevention
and more help in finding a vaccine but
it doesn't mean restricting travel for
now wgo doesn't recommend and actually
opposes any restrictions for travel and
trade or other measures against China
regardless of the decision concern about
the virus has already spread globally
Air France is among the growing list of
Airlines suspending all flights to and
from mainland China sipping demondo
Durrett of cassettes ahead of the cabin
crew Union said staff demanded the
airline take action 6,000 cruise ship
passengers were stopped from
disembarking at an Italian port after a
Chinese woman on board showed symptoms
of corona virus it was later confirmed
she was not infected turkey is among the
countries sending planes to bring
citizens home Spanish and British
citizens will be held in quarantine for
two weeks when they arrive back on
Friday
meanwhile the Philippines and India have
both declared their first cases and in
Thailand stores are selling out of face
masks at a counter to Lee Yoho this
Chinese virologist says it could take
two to four weeks before the virus is
under control but at the current rate
that could mean hundreds of thousands of
people could be infected by then Redman
Shannon Global News London
Canada has not acted as fast as some
other countries to get people out of
Wuhan where there's been a lockdown now
for days almost 200 Canadians who are
stranded want help getting home the
government has a plane in place but
beyond that the logistics are still
being worked out as Abigail Beeman
explains okay we'll talk to you again
shortly as soon as I have news I will
tell you but for Monty Gisborne in
Coquitlam BC and his wife Daniela Lou
enhance there's been no news and finally
got a call from Canadian officials a
formal phone interview they said would
happen in an hour but 12 hours later
nothing Lou along with their daughter
Dominica also in wuhan are permanent
Canadian residents they don't even know
if they'll be allowed on the Canadian
plane whenever it arrives they keep
focusing on the fact that Canadians will
be on that airplane what does that mean
I mean twice it's got a different
perhaps definition than maybe most other
people the risk
we have strong measures in place but no
one can say when the plane Ottawa has
secured will arrive nor what will happen
in terms of screening or isolation we
are flying a non-commercial flight into
a new country that is under quarantine
that has some very strict protocols
about where planes can land and what the
protocols might be and so that requires
negotiations with the Chinese government
Trudeau has asked multiple times about a
global male report saying the government
has already helped some Canadian
diplomat families get out but he
wouldn't answer as so many other
Canadians struggle to get consular help
we are in history right now Montreal air
Felicity Fang is visiting her parents in
Wuhan her father now helping build a new
hospital for coronavirus patients and
she's worried about him for from the
government who told us the viewers stay
inside the chance of your survival is
much bigger than if you go out even
you're aware a lot of protection your
gloves your glasses and your most
importantly your mask this has to be
change like every four hours so many
considerations as Ottawa tries to figure
out how to bring Canadians home the
latest information is 196 people want
consular help of some kind and China is
saying if anyone is sick they won't be
allowed to leave abigail Beeman Global
News Ottawa this virus is a reminder how
interconnected the world is apart from
making so many people in China sick it's
put a chill on doing business with that
country the World Health Organization
made a point to say today China should
not be punished because of this outbreak
and it opposes any restrictions on
travel and trade companies that rely on
the country for their supply chain
though were worried about production as
factories sit idle and today the
American commerce secretary said the
blow to China could be good for American
jobs
Jackson prosecco reports
the world's Factory China is slowing
down production car makers have idled
plants companies like Google and
Facebook have closed their offices the
emerging threat from a new strain of
coronavirus is a reminder of the need to
be vigilant economic experts have warned
it all poses a risk to the already shaky
global economy if companies can't
manufacture their goods and if consumer
demand in the world's second largest
economy drops off in China stores from
Ikea to Starbucks have already shut
their doors what's harder to predict is
what happens over the longer term the
SARS outbreak in 2003 cost the world
economy more than thirty three billion
dollars nearly two decades later China
is a much bigger player now Canada's
second largest trading partner they're
far more connected and that means that
when you have something like the corona
virus the impact felt throughout the
world could be far more significant one
example the ubiquitous iPhone made in
China there are warnings that production
could be vulnerable to supply chain or
labor disruptions and as Airlines
canceled flights to and from the country
the demand side is taking a hit Chinese
tourists the highest per-capita spenders
are staying home we need Chinese
customers because it's Chinese customers
who buy the most says this worried
parents shopkeeper economy comes to a
halt in Washington President Trump's
Commerce Secretary bluntly called
coronavirus and economic win for the US
I think it will help to accelerate the
return of jobs to North America the
reality is with the world economy
already slowing everyone is at rest even
if the corona virus is contained Jackson
prosecco Global News Washington
we explain more about the virus and what
it means to declare a global health
emergency on our website Global News CA
/ global national now - a global news
exclusive we've uncovered a key document
a government document that sheds new
light on Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's
trip to India nearly two years ago he
went there to strengthen Canada India
relations it turned into a diplomatic
disaster he was criticized for
everything from what he wore to the
guest
list our chief political correspondent
David akin obtained the document David
what are we learning about the visit
well Donna it took global news nearly
two years to obtain this a 300 page
briefing book prepared for then foreign
affairs minister Christian Freeland as
she accompanied the prime minister on
his India trip now some sections have
been blacked out by government censors
but there is much that is coming to
light for the first time throughout the
briefing book there is a sense of hope
of optimism that the Trudeau government
could take the relationship to new
heights
this visit the book says has the
potential to reflect a genuine turning
point in the Canada India relationship
well it was a turning point alright turn
in the wrong direction
absolutely the turning point towards a
much worse situation between the two
countries in Canada and in India the
trip flopped amid Snickers at elaborate
Trudeau photo ops and clothing changes
one planned photo op could have been a
doozy Trudeau his wife Sophie and Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi had planned
a joint hour-long yoga session in front
of the cameras that photo op was
cancelled before Trudeau left Canada but
India experts say Canadian planners
seemed not to have had a clear objective
for the trip they haven't gone in with a
plan per se
there's no ask of India and there's no
offer for India and that in itself has
been the challenge to me it reflects the
absence of a larger deeper strategic
agenda but to the Indian government the
trip was a dud for a much more serious
reason the Trudeau government was not
seen as taking Indian concerns about
Sikh terrorism seriously and of course
almost literally blew up at the Final
High Commissioners event with a
convicted would-be assassin that was
somehow on the guest list for this
reception of Canada house and it
couldn't have possibly played worse and
yet the bureaucrats who wrote free lines
briefing book warned
time and again that she and Trudeau must
quote clarify Canada's position with
respect to perceptions of Sikh extremism
in Canada to reset bilateral relations
on a new foot
that 2018 India trip though failed to
reset relations and now two years later
a frozen relationship is just beginning
to thaw Donna okay David in Ottawa
Thanks and tomorrow David will look at
where the relationship between Canada in
India stands now and whether India will
help Canada win a seat on the UN
Security Council the police in Ottawa
have launched a hate crime investigation
after the National Holocaust memorial
was vandalized the monument was pelted
with eggs just days after the 75th
anniversary of the liberation of
Auschwitz a week ago the Ottawa Police
Service announced it is reinstating its
hate crime unit and adding two
investigators to its Security
Intelligence section to address a surge
in hate crimes
it says incidents such as this are
deeply disturbing and will not be
tolerated new suspects in the great
escape of miss Anne's a former boss
coming up the three other people on
Japan's wanted list plus illegal and
historic the record breaking fine
between the u.s. and Mexico and pitas
proposal for Groundhog Day
you
you're looking at the longest
cross-border smuggling tunnel ever
discovered between Mexico and the United
States stretching more than a kilometer
the length of nine football fields the
tunnel runs from San Diego to Tijuana
Mexico and its elaborate equipped with
an extensive rail and car system air
ventilation drainage even an elevator
Mexican officials made the discovery in
August in a Tijuana parking lot for
cargo trucks and worked with US
authorities to map it it's unclear who
built the tunnel but the area has been a
stronghold of Mexico's Sinaloa cartel
prosecutors in Tokyo have issued arrest
warrants for three Americans suspected
of helping Nissan's former boss Carlos
gone escaped from Japan to avoid
criminal charges go and skipped bail and
fled the country in December while
awaiting trial on charges a hiding
income and breach of trust
the warrant claims the three men
including a former US Special Forces
soldier helped smuggle gone in portable
luggage so he could sneak through
immigration checks and get on a private
jet to Turkey the first leg of his
escape he made it to Lebanon that's
where he is now or a whole citizenship
prosecutors also issued an arrest
warrant for Gaughan who they say left
Japan illegally Japan has no extradition
treaty with Lebanon though so it's
unlikely he'll be arrested Facebook has
agreed to pay 550 million dollars to
settle a class-action lawsuit over its
use of facial recognition technology the
software suggested tags for people in
identified in users photos that the
lawsuit alleges violated Illinois's
biometric information Privacy Act
because it took and stored user data
without written permission and did not
tell users how long that data would be
stored
Facebook's settlement will be paid out
to eligible users in Illinois for years
Facebook claimed it had done nothing
wrong but it has now discontinued the
photo tag suggestion tool
a head damage undone evidence it's never
too late for smokers to quit
you are watching global national smoking
is a leading cause of premature death
yet about 15 percent of Canadians
continue to light up the link between
smoking and lung cancer is irrefutable
and it's been widely assumed the damaged
smoking does two lungs can't be undone
now new research from the UK reveals
something surprisingly different Heather
Eurex West explains the medical advice
has been clear for decades to reduce
your risk of cancer and other diseases
don't smoke and if you do quit on
average smoking takes about ten years
off a person's lifespan the previous
research has shown that people who quit
before their early 40s can get about
nine of those years back now scientists
at the University College London have
discovered why we were basically really
interested in what smoking damage there
was in what we would think were normal
cells of the Airways down into the lung
over time the chemicals in tobacco smoke
mutate lung cells slowly changing them
from healthy to cancerous and while it's
been thought those changes were
permanent researchers found that after a
smoker quits their surviving healthy
lung cells can regenerate replacing the
damaged cells we think what's happening
is that there some cells in our lungs
that are sort of perhaps hidden away or
somehow resistant to smoke damage and
then when you stop smoking for some
reason they become sort of more powerful
than they therefore start growing and
expanding and pushing out the smoking
damaged cells researchers found that
after about a decade the lungs of
ex-smokers looked similar to those who
had never smoked bob sumner kicked a
pack-a-day habit 10 years ago overall
like I'm gonna be 61 next month and I
feel so healthy I've been I was one of
the lucky ones my lungs have actually
recovered to the point where I can go
bust a spin class and I actually teach
spin sometimes knowing how lung cells
regenerate could also one day lead to
new therapies if we can put to stop
smoking then we could perhaps give them
a drug or an inhaler or something to
these cells grow out and there
or protect them from actually developing
cancer in the first place giving even
longtime smokers a new reason to quit
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
leveling the track why this shoe may get
the boot
you know this guy he and his
predecessors have been predicting winter
Zen for over a century
well now the animal rights group PETA
says it's time for Punxsutawney Phil to
retire they believe an artificial
intelligence robot should replace the
rodents but with just three days to go
until we find out if he's seen his
shadow or not Phil's not likely to get
this Groundhog Day off for elite runners
every fraction of a second counts and
now there are claims a shoe could be
giving some top marathoners an unfair
advantage
the shoes are called vapour flies Nike
claims they are the fastest shoes
they've ever made the international
governing body for track and field is
looking at whether the shoes actually
violate the rules Geoff simple reports
this two-time Olympic marathon runner is
training for the Summer Games in Tokyo
and this time round he's adding an extra
spring to his step the second you put on
your feet you just know that it's
there's more spring to it read cool sad
recently laced up a pair of Nike Vapor
flies the running shoes could shave
precious seconds off of his run time
that is assuming he's still allowed to
wear them if there's shoes that are
faster and they're allowed by world
athletics I want to be in them too I
don't want to be left behind Nike Vapor
fly is widely considered the fastest
shoe on the track the secret is in the
soul it contains high efficiency foam
fused with a carbon fiber plate curbed
under the front helping a runner rock
from heel to toe when a runner's foot
hits the pavement much of the energy
propelling them forward is lost but one
study found the vapor fly shoe retains
around 4% more energy in a marathon
that's enough to shave 2% off of a run
time 2% is monstrous that's the
difference between a gold medal a world
record since they're released in 2016
the shoes have shattered world records
raising questions about whether Nike has
taken its tech a step too far
small organizations are trying to
negotiate how much technology to permit
before it be
comes about the technology and not the
athlete track-and-field is far from the
only sport struggling with how to
balance talent with tech in the 1960s
pole-vaulting raised the bar by allowing
controversial fiberglass poles while
Swimming's governing body banned high
tech super suits that made swimmers more
buoyant after Michael Phelps threatened
to boycott competitions they attempted
to hold the line at that particular
point because the suits were improving
every six months you know when when they
were out and so that looks like it's
gonna start happening with the shoes now
on Friday world athletics is expected to
tighten its regulations regarding high
tech running shoes but it will likely
still allow Nike Vapor fly to run its
course
Geoff supple Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is porcupine lake near
Timmins Ontario we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye bye
[Music]
you